facts without fear we are the American
people we are the home of the brave land
of the free this is important now as
written the bill scary it is scary top
six trillion dollars for that trillion
dollars is money that money's for
liquidity from the Federal Reserve in
other words loans from the federal
government two trillion new spending a
lot of money a lot of people need help
I'll explain in a second
that includes direct funding federal
payouts to American workers they
desperately need it
we this has gone on too long they are
struggling through no fault of their own
workers small businesses and even even
entire industries now need our help and
now help hopefully will be on the way
without these delays now this bill also
provides much-needed financial relief
for small businesses the heart and soul
of our business industry in the country
and even large industries who are on the
brink of collapse their businesses wiped
out temporarily
and with that said let me say this to
all you Democrats and Republicans in
Washington I don't trust anything that
you do any waste any fraud any abuse any
corruption and he give back any pork any
special benefits for CEOs stock buybacks
we will be calling all of you out by
name and holding all of you accountable
with this crisis every single penny that
we put forward needs to go to the
American workers that are impacted small
businesses and the businesses that are
larger impacted by the virus for days we
have now been watching a shift show the
radical socialist Democrats at their
absolute worst this has been repulsive
this important legislation now has been
blocked for days by these radical
leftists hurting workers hurting
business hurting people that need help
Pelosi Schumer and company decided this
would be the perfect time to play dirty
political games they wanted to take
advantage of a deadly virus use that to
push their radical leftist socialist
agenda including bucket loads of
wasteful unrelated spending proposals
many of which can be found in Acacio
Cortez's new Green Deal insanity
look at your screen this is Nancy Pelosi
this is what Nancy Pelosi's have been
fighting for her wish list including tax
credits for wind and solar power strict
new regulations against the already
struggling airline industry why don't we
just kick them in the teeth while
they're struggling including mandatory
emissions reductions for airplanes
mandatory reporting of their greenhouse
gas emissions statistics for individual
flight kick the airline industry in the
teeth when they are down it is
despicable what they are doing that's
not all the socialist wish list also
proposes 35 million dollars this will
make every American worker that's
struggling to make their rent or their
mortgage payment and their car payment
he's wondering if they're gonna be able
to send the kids to college oh yeah they
want to put the kennedy performing arts
thirty-five million dollars for that
they want to fix that up really that's
what the delay is about because in a
time like this Pelosi really needs her
favorite Opera House so she can stay in
tip-top emotional shape and then there's
more Pelosi demanding new protections
for illegal immigrants is this the time
the automatic extension of non-immigrant
visas sweeping new collective bargaining
powers were their big donors the unions
racial diversity quotas on the quotas on
the boards of major companies
elimination of student debt new mandate
requiring States to allow same-day voter
registration oh how are we gonna check
that out and get this Pelosi wants to
bring back the Obama phone once you
thought it was done and gone that's
right her bill includes federal
subsidies for cellphones now what does
any of this have to do with coronavirus
you might ask that question the answer
is absolutely nothing suffering
Americans have been waiting the whole
time in this crisis and this is how they
act in what they do every American
should be disgusted tonight three long
years hate Trump and do nothing else
nothing to make us more safe secure
prosperous nothing nothing to create a
job do any of these radical socialist
proposals are they going to get
paychecks to restaurant workers small
business owner
and those employees or anyone else
suffering not a thing at a time when
Americans actually could use their
government stepping up to work for and
serve we the people that's supposed to
be public servants well they're getting
the middle finger from Washington a
national disgrace unfolding tonight take
a look
we saw the Speaker of the House
releasing encyclopedia of unrelated
demands as though it were a coronavirus
proposal somehow Democrats have been
delaying a major relief bill in hopes
that they can include a laundry list of
their pet projects projects that have
absolutely nothing to do with providing
financial relief to Americans I honestly
cannot believe we are still here not
having already passed legislation that
would make such a big difference I have
never been more disgusted since
Cavanaugh let's get this straight the
American people paid - we pay to rebuild
Europe after World War two we continue
to send constant billions and billions
of dollars in international aid all over
the world we defeated Nazism fascism
communism and more recently radical
radical Islamic terrorism we've saved
the world and paid the highest price
from evil again and again and gotten
through a number of other conflicts and
pandemics and depression but now
Congress can't get paychecks to the
American people in need at this hour
because Nancy Pelosi wants more
windmills and carbon offsets just like
the last three years what they are doing
is hurting the country and thankfully
tonight despite the shameful actions
from Pelosi Schumer radical socialist
economic relief hopefully we're going to
find out they're supposed to be back in
session any minute now we'll be on the
way